bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 3 novembre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur
l'actualité locale entouré de nos
invités et des journalistes de la
rédaction on commence tout de suite avec
les titres de cette émission
la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
versailles yvelines vient de dévoiler
les résultats de son enquête sur la
consommation dans les yvelines
elle permet de dresser les grandes
tendances et dope d'adapter l'offre sur
le territoire invité sylvie l'amener à
la directrice est divine tourisme avec
elle nous parlerons de l'opération goût
divine qui débute le 14 novembre
au programme de nombreuses animations
autour de la cuisine pour découvrir les
produits locaux
après la finalisation des accords la
présentation des listes pour les
régionales le parti socialiste vient de
dévoiler le nom des candidats pour les
régionales en île de france
et rappelez-vous le 1er mai dernier la
mort du jeune moussa avait attrapé avait
soulevé une vague d'émotion âgé de 14
ans avait reçu une balle de pistolet
mitrailleur en bas de son immeuble dans
le square albert camus près de six mois
après un suspect a été interpellé selon
nos confrères du parisien l'affairé liée
à une rivalité concernant le contrôle de
trafic de stupéfiants à trappes et du
suspect qui se trouvait alors dans une
voiture qui serait impliqué dans cette
fusillade était en cavale
le plus jeune d'entre eux a été
interpellé puis placé en garde à vue
dans les locaux de la police judiciaire
à versailles une grande marche en
hommage à moussa avait été organisée le
4 mai à trappes et plus de 2000
personnes avaient salué la mémoire du
jeune garçon
enfin quels sont vos habitudes de
consommation c'est une question qui
intéresse la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de versailles yvelines
elle a révélé ce matin les résultats de
son enquête plus les pôles qui tue les
comportements d'achat des consommateurs
dans notre département
réaliser une fois tous les quatre on
vient 31 mille questionnaires sont mis
l'acte d'achat ils sont analysés
retour sur cette enquête avec fanny
bourdon
évolution des comportements d'achat et à
des commerces de proximité ou encore
impact des centres commerciaux la cci
versailles a révélé ce matin une grande
enquête plus ripoll sur le commerce dans
notre département
l'outil comporte toute l'offre
commerciale sur le territoire et donc
maintenant les habitudes d'achat des
consommateurs on sait précisément où ils
vont acheter
pour quels types de produits à quelle
fréquence et qu'elle est l'attractivité
de notre territoire notre territoire
quand même très attractif une
attractivité due notamment aux centres
commerciaux la zone de plaisir les clés
est la grande gagnante de cette enquête
c'est le premier pôle commercial du
département
les commerces de proximité sont plus en
reste plus les commerces de proximité
sont en difficulté évidemment ça se voit
il ya pas besoin de par contre
effectivement ce qu'on a appris ce matin
c'est que il n'y avait pas une grosse
grosse chute sur l'ensemble mais qu'il y
avait effectivement des secteurs
beaucoup plus sinistrées que d'autres
effectivement ça joue aussi sur le
pouvoir d'achat des zones étudiées quoi
les consommateurs sont de plus en plus
exigeants et connecté d'où le besoin
pour ces petits commerces de répondre à
ces nouvelles attentes
on l'a entendu aujourd'hui les camps
centres devront faire un effort
important pour se mettre au goût du jour
d'un point de vue de la modernité c'est
important qu'ils veulent se mettre sur
internet qu'ils puissent trouver des
solutions numériques pour attirer
davantage de consommateurs ou en tout
cas garder leur attractivité
à l'issue de cette réunion publique
collectivités et commerçants ont pu
échanger mais une incertitude persiste
la loi macron avec l'ouverture des
commerces le dimanche pourrait impacter
les commerces de proximité et la scène
n'a pas monté de surprendre samedi matin
devant l'entrée de la gare de montigny
le bretonneux
une quinzaine de personnes vous le voyez
à l'image s'est introduit dans une
agence bancaire pour en ressortir
quelques minutes plus tard avec lui
chaises une opération menée par un
collectif baptisé actions non violentes
comme 21 qui entendent dénoncer
l'évasion et la fraude fiscale organisée
par les banques
le collectif soutient la désobéissance
civile pour appeler les responsables
politiques à se tourner vers la finance
pour alimenter un fonds vert pour le
climat en décembre
196 partis membres de l'onu doivent se
retrouver à paris pour un sommet sur
l'environnement actions non-violentes
coop 21 annoncent ne pouvoir
réquisitionné symboliquement autant de
chaises dans les prochains jours
travers la france et comme chaque mardi
dans le journal nous parlons à présent
politique bonsoir bonsoir florin et bien
sûr et les questions à des élections
régionales chacune des formations
finalistes finalise ses listes à cinq
semaines du premier tour qui se tiendra
le dimanche 6 décembre 209 sièges sont à
pourvoir en ile de france petit rappel
les départements qui composent les
régions établissent chacun leur propre
liste derrière un candidat qui les
fédère tous c'est la tête de liste pour
le parti socialiste dont on va parler
dans quelques instants c'est claude
bartolone par exemple et en fonction des
résultats dans le département un certain
nombre des postulants sont appelés ou
non assiégée d'où l'importance de bien
figurer dans le haut de la liste pour
s'assurer une place même en cas de
défaite au second tour bien sûr et d'où
la difficulté surtout à les établir ces
listes surtout en cas d'accord avec flux
de plusieurs formations politiques ainsi
le parti socialiste qui avait déjà donné
les premiers noms vient de procéder en
fin de semaine dernière à quelques
ajustements
elles sont surprises sandrine grand
gambe responsable départemental des
socialistes reste numéro 1 dans les
yvelines juste devant benoît hamon
député beaucoup de renouvellement avec
rama sall à mantes la jolie qui
représentent aussi l'avenir pour la
gauche sur le territoire du mantois avec
saïd benmouffok aussi à mantes la ville
nous avons aussi le sud yvelines qui est
présenté
largement par une jeune candidate qui
est diane la couture ce rambouillet mais
évidemment aussi le maire de saintes et
renoue jean claude husson qui écrit au
présent sur le haut de liste c'est
important pour nous donc vraiment une
représentation assez large tous les
territoires
le parti socialiste qui a donc fait un
accord avec l'union des démocrates
écologistes le mouvement républicain et
citoyen ou encore le prg le parti
radical de gauche eddie ait son
représentant local l'ancien maire de
carrières sous poissy et numéro quatre
sur sept listes de gauche donc dans les
yvelines
j'ai une véritable satisfaction à voir
la gauche rassemblée sur la liste de
claude bartolone dans les yvelines
autour de sandrine grand g je dirais que
la situation personnelle qui est la
mienne d'être situé en quatre mais très
satisfaisante mais importe peu
aujourd'hui au regard des enjeux que
nous avons à conserver cette région à
gauche depuis 2004 je participe aux
listes aux élections régionales est donc
le parti radical de gauche un parti
républicain ancrée dans l'histoire de la
république attache au principe de
laïcité c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons rejoint claude bartolone qui
s'était engagé à mettre en oeuvre un
observatoire régional de la laïcité
c'est pas un point fort pour nous de
convergence avec lui un accord entre
plusieurs formations politiques de
gauche mais toujours pas d'alliance
entre les verts ou encore le front
gauche et les partenaires de la majorité
sortante veulent donc se compter comme
on dit chacun de tester sa popularité
auprès des électeurs et surtout obtenir
une légitimité pour peser ensuite dans
le programme qui sera proposé en commun
lors du second tour une stratégie
inverse à celle qui est menée par la
droite les républicains ont déjà
fusionné leur liste avec lui d y encore
le modem le programme du ps qui
s'articule bien sûr autour de la défense
du bilan de jean paul huchon et puis
quelques propositions fortes la mise en
place d'une offre transport 24 heures
sur 24 en ile de france a l'obligation
faite aux commmunes de respecter les
obligations de logements sociaux pour
pouvoir prétendre à des subventions mais
lors de cette conférence de presse
organisée en fin de semaine dernière
c'est surtout la volonté de déstabiliser
valérie pécresse qui prime et côté
benoît hamon je constate que la grèce
est d'ores et déjà dans
manas sorte de lobby qui sont très
influents qui sont à droite
sens commun
la manif pour tout ce qu'elle leur fait
une large place il ya donc des gens qui
sont très favorables mariage pour tous
des gens totalement opposées moi la
question que je pose c'est si quel sera
le comportement de ces élus demain dans
l'assemblée régionale
quand on évoquera la question des menus
scolaires quand on évoquera la question
des semaines d'éducation à la sexualité
est l'ami contre l'homophobie à
l'ouverture des lycéens d'ile-de-france
pense qu'il n'y a aujourd'hui un poids
des idées réactionnaires extrêmement
fort et qui s'illustre par nos pas un
représentant mais plusieurs
représentants rien sur la liste des
yvelines et c'est ce qui me semble la
caractéristique aujourd'hui mais valérie
pécresse qui est outre on pourrait donc
de notables désignés mais surtout
à peut-être pas aujourd'hui le
tempérament ou la force de caractère
suffisante pour résister à ces lobbys
n'en comprend pas la charge est lourde
vous l'avez entendu mais pour l'emporter
il va falloir marquer les esprits les
républicains sont pour l'instant en tête
c'est des différents sondages sur notre
région ile-de-france et puis concernant
le parti socialiste cette dernière
information claude bartelone la tête de
liste régionale donc qui sera en meeting
lundi 9 novembre à banques la jolie nous
y reviendrons bien évidemment merci à
wilfred enfin connaissez vous vous
connaissez peut-être le bondy blog mais
connaissez vous son petit frère le trafi
blog
dix ans après les émeutes le bondy blog
a porté ses fruits quand à l'image des
banlieues
sur le même modèle donc un blog qui
donne la parole aux jeunes mais deal it
in qui est originaire de guyancourt et
ans un ancien élève de sciences po paris
a fondé depuis le 1er octobre le trapu
blog
ils cherchent de nouvelles plumes
reportage de sephora namani et patrick
jacq dx mais de lutter à travers la
plume c'est toute l'ambition des jeunes
autour de cette table rédacteur pour le
très petit blog
il souhaite tordre le cou aux clichés
sur les banlieues véhiculée selon eux
par les médias j'ai un master dans la
littérature générale et comparée et
banquets je trouve que ça colle bien
écrire dans les blogs et surtout écrire
pour ma ville pour valoriser ma vie et
pour changer
l'image est entre parenthèses
stéréotypes aperçu sur la ville de
trappes à l'instar du bondy blog mais
dit victime enfant de la banlieue passé
par sciences po paris a souhaité donner
la parole aux jeunes de trappes à
travers ce projet dont il est le
fondateur leur offrir en fait un espace
sur lequel ils pourront exprimer leurs
idées et aussi se former à exprimer ses
idées via les cris mais aussi ça peut
être sous format radio ou formats vidéo
où toute nue ou tout autre moyen en fait
dès que d'exprimer ce qu'ils ont à
exprimer réunion touquet deux semaines
pour l'équipe du traspy blog depuis le
1er octobre pour évoquer ensemble les
sujets d'écriture ici pas de sang sur la
forme est libre on peut écrire
presque tout ce qu'on veut même la forme
est très libre du coup ça m'a beaucoup
plu parce que j'ai
j'ai souvent du mal à dire ce que je
pense mais par écrit c'est beaucoup plus
facile pour moi et j'ai sauté sur
l'occasion
une dizaine de blogueurs dont alain
degois alias pas qu'ils forment déjà la
plus en du traspy blog qui est ce
personnage de plus en plus de lecteurs
pour revaloriser l'image les banlieues
et nous sommes en plateau avec sylvie
luna directrice divine tourisme bonsoir
à vous bonsoir merci d'être venus en
plateau vous êtes ici pour nous parler
de la troisième édition de coup divine
qui se déroule du 14 au 22 novembre est
le parrain cette année
simone zanoni chef du trianon palace à
versailles et deux étoiles au michelin
alors avec cette opération c'est la
cuisine mais aussi la consommation et
elle est à l'honneur c'est ça puisque en
fait notre fil conducteur ce sont les
produits locaux
c'est découvrir les produits locaux des
yvelines à l'occasion de cette
manifestation
c'est vrai qu'on est un département
d'île de france et on a peu souvent idée
de penser qu'il y a énormément de
produits qui se font sur place
et bien c'est pour le faire connaître
nous avons organisé cet événement à la
zone en plein plein de pubs de
découverte et je vais vous en parler
alors justement consommer local est ce
important pour vous est ce une habitude
que vous avez c'est la question que nous
vous avons posé regardez pas pour
l'instant je sais qu'il ya un marché ici
je crois mais j'ai pas encore pris le
temps de définir quand j'en ai la
possibilité je fais mes courses
oui bien sûr on déjà et à moins de
pollution le transport des aliments et
la chine oui oui oui bien sûr je pense
que déjà c'est une bonne chose et
consommer local oui dans la mesure du
possible je le ferai je gère seul et les
circuits courts
pourquoi faire venir sa de l'étranger ou
d'ailleurs pas surtout potentiellement
la france ensuite bon je suis pas très
attaché aux circuits courts où on
s'engage sur des paniers des choses
comme ça on ne sait pas ce que ça je
trouve que c'est trop contraignant
c'est très important mais je fais pas
attention à ça parce que cherche un
rapport qualité prix et en général c'est
vrai commencé par faire des économies on
achète des choses qui n'ont pas
forcément local alors si maintenant on
voit quand même beaucoup de gens qui se
sentent concernés par la consommation
locale
oui est de plus en plus dans les
yvelines autant qu'ailleurs les circuits
courts comme le disait si bien une dame
qu'on vient d'entendre sont très
importants d'abord
on en est sûrs de la provenance du
produit on sait très bien qu'il ait
parlé dans les frigos kid est arrivée
quasi direct sur notre table et c'est ce
qu'on s'emploie à faire connaître dans
cette manifestation
good yvelines justement c'est très
important tout le monde a envie de
retourner aux sources un petit peu un on
a on a besoin de retrouver les
traditions et ce qu'on a un peu perdu et
c'est ce que nous essayons de faire
redécouvrir aux habitants des yvelines
et aux franciliens bien sûr plus
largement par savoir faire local aussi
un peu l'artisanat qui est mis également
en avant avec à sa troisième édition
c'est ça c'est tout ce qui se fait sur
place l'artisanat local
par exemple les chocolatiers lors du
lancement de good yvelines qui est à
versailles il ya deux grandes grandes
zones d'animation à versailles le 15 il
y à nu paris place de la cathédrale
saint louis on aura plus de 40
partenaires il ya des fous de trucs
comme ça on peut passer la journée sur
place et des spectacles pour enfants
également
il ya un espace chef ou cinq chefs vont
venir faire des démonstrations et on
pourra même déguster leurs fabrications
donc ça c'est important
pour ceux qui ne pourraient pas rentrer
dans l'espace yale chef il ya des télés
à l'extérieur pour pouvoir voir la
retransmission
et puis vous avez un concours de cuisine
amateur c'est très tendance donc nous
aussi on l'a fait et l'année dernière il
a déjà existé et les nominés après on
les suit tout le temps et on est on est
gravie de les avoir fait progresser
puisque certains ont font après leur
métier alors il ya des ateliers pour
tous les âges pour les adultes et aussi
pour les enfants
absolument on peut faire des tartes au
chocolat avec le restaurant le onze qui
qui est à versailles et dont le chef
sévit sur l'espace chef
on peut faire des choux on peut faire
des muffins des cookies voilà c'est pour
laisser pour les adultes mais aussi pour
les enfants bien sûr ce que c'est très
familial à notre manifestation
je vous ai dit qu'il y avait des
spectacles aussi donc c'est vraiment
pour toute la famille et puis non
seulement il ya ce lancement mais tout
au long de la manifestation pendant
quinze jours vingt dix jours plus
exactement
il y à tout un tas de d'événements tout
un tas de manifestations où toute la
famille peut participer par exemple il
ya un grand dîner dans le château mairie
du mesnil-saint-denis c'est vraiment
exceptionnel le château est magnifique
et c'est un dîner pour god yvelines
on a un produit local qu'est le yaourt y
qui a été fabriquée dans les yvelines et
sur lequel il va y avoir des ateliers
pour savoir comment on peut l'agrémenter
de fruits on peut le consommer sucré
salé
voilà plein plein de choses en fait qui
rassemble la convivialité les produits
locaux les changes et des manifestations
pour toute la famille donc chaque année
vous divine c'est vraiment l'initiative
qui grandit est ce que cette année il ya
vraiment des nouveautés particulières
vous avez plus de partenaires il me
semble oui beaucoup plus de partenaires
déjà il ya deux espaces pour le
lancement à versailles il n'y en avait
qu'un l'année dernière donc on a quasi
doublé le nombre de partenaires on a
toujours nos marchés fermiers pour la
clôture donc il y en a à mantes en même
temps que la foire à l'oignon rappelons
que c'est un événement très
traditionnelle c'est à 560 7e foire à
l'oignon donc ça date un peu de soleil
tous les ans ensuite on en a un peu
marre chez ati verbal grignon dans la
ferme
donc on est déjà au sein de la
fabrication produits locaux et on
apporte d'autres de domaine d'ô de
partenaires et puis il y en a à
chevreuse là où il ya beaucoup de
produits fabriqués sur place dans le
parc naturel régional
donc oui de plus en plus de partenaires
et on fait se rencontrer des gens qui ne
se connaissaient pas qu'ils vont
travailler ensemble ça c'est aussi
l'objectif de good yvelines des
restaurateurs qui rencontre des
producteurs locaux qui vont se mettre à
travailler ensemble
on a par exemple le chef de la tour
d'argent à paris qui n'est pas du tout
il dit doit en tout cas mais qui
travaille avec un producteur des
yvelines parce qu'il juge que sa
production est exceptionnel donc vous
voyez on s'exporte un petit peu jusqu'à
là jusqu'à la capitale donc le pet aussi
c'est de montrer qu'il ya plein de
richesses dans les producteurs et plein
de riches dans les producteurs locaux
des civils est ce que ce soit aussi de
faire prendre conscience aux yvelinois
l'importance de bien s'alimenter ça
passe aussi par là bien sûr bien sûr
c'est très très important et tout au
long de l'année on a un blog qui
évidemment qui bat son plein au moment
de de good yvelines mais qui aussi dure
toute l'année avec des idées de recettes
des idées un peu plus light que d'autres
on utilise des légumes est le thème de
cette année c'est comment travailler un
produit dit pauvre que ça soit un légume
ou autre et le sublime et à partir d'une
recette donc il n'y a pas besoin
forcément d'investir dès mille et des
cents dans une recette pour qu'elle soit
extraordinaire il suffit juste de savoir
comment comment s'y prendre et saül
explique sur le blog et c'est tout tout
aussi le fil conducteur de notre
événement alors si justement voilà on a
envie de participer à cette troisième
édition de coup divine comment ça se
passe comment on fait pour se renseigner
un petit peu alors on va sur le blog
good yvelines
www good evening tout accroché point fr
et on s'inscrit à des ateliers donc le
15 il faut s'inscrire et pour ceux qui
auront qui n'ont pas eu la chance
d'avoir des places parce que la plupart
des ateliers sont gratuits
à ce moment les viennent quand même et
puis il ya des choses que sur lesquels
on peut participer comme la fédération
française de cuisine amateur qui nous
propose le concours ou bien l'atelier
des chefs qu'on peut regarder en
retransmission extérieur sur les écrans
fayard a quand même
il y en aura pour tout le monde tout le
monde peut venir nous voir il y avait
beaucoup de mou de l'année dernière on
espère te rend encore plus cette année
une dernière question à sylviane avons
deux complices conclure cet entretien ce
que vous avez une petite préférence un
atelier voilà une initiative qui vous
tient particulièrement à coeur
dans cette troisième édition go divine
alors moi c'est l'espace chef c'est
comme l'année dernière effectivement
ménochet prendront beaucoup plus de
temps à expliquer et à faire leur
démonstration que l'année dernière donc
l'espace chef c'est quasiment une heure
et demie pour chaque chef
ils vont faire leur démonstration et
après ils font goûter leur leurs
produits qu'ils auront réalisé sur place
après il ya le nettoyage pour que le
chef d'après arrivé il ya aussi tout un
tas de questions qu'on pourra poser à
ses chefs
donc c'est peut-être un moment un petit
peu privilégié dans la manifestation qui
ne se reproduit pas tous les jours
c'est vraiment si on y vient c'est
exceptionnel l'occasion de rencontrer de
grands chefs et des astuces et des
conseils alors il ya plein de
d'activités d'animation à versailles sur
saint quentin en yvelines à son entrée
de territoire il ya le 14 novembre la
visite avec démonstration et réalisation
d'une recette chez le cheval le
chocolatier dobosz à montigny le
bretonneux
il ya aussi un atelier création de
cocktails bien-être à la verrière le
même jour à 14h30 et la sncf renouvelle
son opération paniers fraîcheur et
propose cette année pour hbo divine de
gares et les noix supplémentaire des
dégustations et aussi des petits cadeaux
pour tout le monde alors je le rappelle
goût divine c'est du 14 au 22 novembre
si vous voulez vous renseigner n'hésitez
pas allez donc sur le blog
www.codever.fr merci beaucoup à sylvie
léonard
merci et l'association étudiante poèmes
de l'université de 50 ans d'une organise
comme chaque année un gala cette année
c'est le vendredi 27 novembre à paris et
les profits seront reversés à l'eau ce à
l'association imagine fort margot cette
association lutte contre les cancers
pédiatriques en soutenant des programmes
de recherche européens et plus
localement en soutenant les enfants
malades et leurs familles dans les
hôpitaux de la région
vous pouvez donc retirer les places le 4
et le 6 novembre à l ufr de santé de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
une cagnotte est lancé pour récolter des
dons
la fondation de l'université s'est
engagé à reverser le double de ce qui
sera récoltée et enfin mai dernier 8
auto entrepreneuse avait lancé un salon
du bien-être féminin à bois d'arcy
devant le succès de l'opération elles
ont proposé ce week-end le premier salon
de l'automne avec cette fois 23
exposants artisans auto entrepreneuse et
vendeuses à domicile s'était alors donné
rendez vous mélanie paul kate et william
elle pour ce reportage et les mouvements
circulaires cullers pape lance un peu on
peut appuyer on peut aller en profondeur
ça fera jamais de mal ça fera que du
bien
sylvie da cruz est masseuse
professionnelle elle pratique
principalement ses massages dans des
entreprises
alors ce genre de salon c'est un moyen
de rencontre
gco des prestations
à donner donc j'ai pas de quelque chose
de concret à vendre donc c'est pour me
faire connaître
réussir à avoir des contacts dans les
comités d'entreprise voire des drh des
choses comme ça qui pourrait être mise
en place dans leur entreprise
coiffure maquillage le salon d'automne
regrouper 23 exposants artisans
auto-entrepreneurs et vendeuses à
domicile
que ce soit pour les artisans les auto
entrepreneurs ou les personnes enlevées
dei c'est avant tout la possibilité de
montrer ce dont ils sont capables l'eure
l'eure leurs marques leurs leur secteur
d'activité faire connaître également
leurs talents leurs produits et surtout
surtout prendre des contacts
devant le succès de cette édition le
salon d'automne devrait être renouvelée
l'an prochain et enfin mots de sport
pour finir car oui c'est du sport une
grande compétition de billard était
organisé ce week-end à fontenay le
fleury plus de 170 joueurs classés parmi
les meilleurs joueurs français et
étrangers se sont affrontés au gymnase
descartes à l'occasion du 3e open des
billes a organisé par la fédération
française ni quel ennemi d'euros et
william elles ont suivi la compétition
pour nos goûts de la concentration de la
logique main assurée et une part de
chance 170 joueurs ont joué des coudes
ce week-end un fontenay-le-fleury pour
remporter l'open de billard organisée
par la fédération française
les compétitions programmées pour la
4ème année consécutive dans la ville
ivy noir j'ai poussé la porte de la
mairie il ya quatre ans ils m'ont dit
oui pour la première année ils ont voulu
voir a plus maintenant c'est tous les
ans fait la même époque at on n'ose pas
être open national de billard et veuves
et sa promo en national voire même
internationale que les étrangers qui
sont avec nous qui l'a 9 dans l'année et
u9 ont fait un par région ce mois ci
c'est à paris donc donc affronter furic
nous accueille gentiment
puis la quatrième édition c'est
individuel aujourd'hui et demain c'est
en équipe du qatar se classe dans le
gymnase descartes des têtes d'affiché 36
sélectionnable pour les championnats
d'europe et du monde ont participé à cet
open
le destin de la discipline yannick
beaufils classé dans le top 8 mondial
était de la partie et un très bon niveau
il ya les meilleurs joueurs français qui
participent
il ya une grande partie des meilleurs
joueurs français qui participe ce
week-end à la hauteur nationale fontenay
pour gagner un open il n'y a pas de
secret il faut être en forme et faille
bien dans sa tête mentalement et avoir
de l'endurance
dans la catégorie des meilleurs joueurs
français le tournoi s'est soldée par la
victoire en finale de victorin la barre
de bordeaux contre cdh avec le quellec
de vitré rendez vous l'année prochaine à
fontenay le fleury pour une nouvelle
édition
et c'est la fin de cette édition je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis demain
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal nous
parlons de la campagne de vaccination
contre la grippe avec un médecin qui
nous donnera tout c'est tous ces
conseils ainsi que sont na vi je vous
retrouve donc demain à 18h en direct
pour une nouvelle édition du 7 8 le
journal je vous souhaite une très bonne
soirée